you
[Music]
we'll start the next session this is on
AI for societal impact it's it's an area
that is close to our hearts in MSR and I
think MIT will probably give more
details so I'll introduce the track
owner it's my great pleasure to
introduce Amit Sharma who's from
Microsoft Research India emitted his PhD
from Cornell and joined us you know some
time back and his research interests are
in the area of causality and recently I
think he's also doing some interesting
work on on mental health and he's
extremely passionate about the potential
for AI to do social good societal impact
and I'll hand it over to Amit and I'm
sure he's he'll also introduce what we
what I'm sure is a very interesting set
of speakers that we have over the next
hour and a half so overdo it thank you
for this introduction as I said I think
at MSR we are very passionate about
having societal impact with the research
projects that we do and we thought of in
this data science AI summit we thought
of having a session focused on how these
technologies can help us have social
impact right so one thing that I think
is not new to almost all of you is that
AI and machine learning are having a
transformative impact right
and I just would give you one sort of
anecdote or one sort of question you can
ask researchers is what are the problems
in computer vision or natural language
processing or even reinforcement
learning which deals with control theory
and making decisions that you could not
solve ten years ago right and you can
even today find examples even on phones
that you use that there have been
computer vision advances that were not
possible ten years ago in 2008
there have been translation and natural
language there have been automatic
generation of natural language that was
unheard of ten years ago and similarly
in reinforcement learning we are now
seeing more and more control
applications that seemed like impossible
right so it's not just that we are
making advances it's just that we made a
huge advance in our capabilities in AI
right and so obviously one set of events
that have happened
that it's been starting to use
everywhere right so for example in the
West especially and in many countries
we're already seeing machine learning
being used in companies to automate
processes giving scene we are seeing it
being used in different types of even
sort of field work for example education
agriculture smartphone usage and so on
right and so they've been big concerns
that have come up one is of course job
automation so with this new technology
especially so powerful there are many
concerns about how the future economy is
going to look like there are also
concerns about fairness and
responsibility if you are now deploying
for example take the first example
deploying a technology app that helps us
kid learn you have to be really sure
that whatever content that's being
provided is responsible it's not sort of
learning some bad patterns that are not
good for the student and more
importantly you also want to make sure
that technologies such as in healthcare
or finance are being fair to all kinds
of represented and underrepresented
groups right so there's this part that
has taken a lot of attention both in the
press and in recent media this session
though even though we understand that
all of these are big concerns we want to
focus on the positive side right so with
any technology what impact can it have
on our society and especially as
researchers and people living in India
there are many problems where it is
possible that AI and technology can be
useful but I think what we want to do in
this session is to just bring some
perspective on what's possible and what
is the right way to go about it right
let me just touch a few examples in this
long list of problems you can think of
as societal problems and the sense that
they are motivated by conditions in our
society and they're impacting us in
different walks of our life in health
care and education a country like ours
faces a huge shortage in trained
professionals you can imagine
ái being useful in helping people to
deliver effective services
similarly in Financial Inclusion and
governance we have great in efficiencies
and you can think of ways in which AI or
machine learning can help you be much
more efficient and much more transparent
in how things are but at the same time
we also have to be asking us this
question which is interestingly what I
also get asked when I talk to people who
are outside this machine learning is
there and people ask what's different
this time
right and I hope in this session today
we also ask this question of it's great
but what's different right so technology
and societal impact is not a new dream
it was there when computers were
introduced in the 1980s and 90s it was
there with the internet being an enabler
of communication across the world and
it's still there with mobile phones and
the ability for people to have a
communication device right with them if
this one thing that we have learnt that
are both through research at our group
in Microsoft research and through other
ICT work is that technology cannot just
be a fix for societal problems that we
have right and one of the nicest sort of
expressions to think about is that it
can only act as an amplifier of the
social forces that we have right so for
example if you have a great educational
institution if you add technology to it
provide all students great apps to learn
most likely they'll do well but if you
don't and in think instead you have a
situation where the school is not
running well they're not enough teachers
just sort of magically introducing apps
that learn would not help students as
much right and if you're interested
there's a former researcher at a lab
quintero to Emma who's written a book on
this whole idea of techno determinism
and so in this session what I hope we
can do is to take both of these
perspectives and present you both active
research and practical projects that
people are working on in this
area right and based on our experience
what we found at least at Microsoft
Research is that these four things are
the most important whenever you're
thinking of applying AI for societal
impact or in any technology for that
matter and I'll walk through this but I
think the first thing to see here is
that there's nothing technical in these
four points it's often not about having
a deep technical advancement or end or
an insight it's often about finding the
right problem where ml can have an
impact working with excellent domain
experts or people organizations who have
expertise in the problem that you're
dealing with so that you're not just
sort of going blind with the
correlations you find and finally a big
focus on deployment and testing I hope
in the panel discussion we'll also toss
or talk about what's the right
expectation of success success means
different things especially in the
research world and in practice and
especially for a thorny issue as a
societal problem there can be different
expectations of what it means to have a
success so over the past few months and
this year at MSR we have started this
collaborative project keeping in mind
these four points where we are thinking
of working and collaborating with
organizations across academia and the
social enterprises to actually then
identify these problems where yeah I can
have an impact and we are very fortunate
that today we have four speakers some of
whom we are also collaborating with who
have tackled this hard problem in many
sort of different domains right so we
have a great sort of diversity in the
kinds of problems you'll hear about
today and how machine learning and AI
can help from grinching from how do you
have better wildlife tracking and
conservation to how do you think about
tackling fake news and misinformation in
the society and then also we'll also
hear both from researchers as well as
people who are doing the groundwork for
at Fratton Books is an NGO that's look
to use AI for making children read books
in whatever language they wish to
and finally Roanoke is going to talk
about a problem that I think especially
in India many of us are increasingly
concerned with which is air pollution
and how do you design intelligent
sensors to tackle that problem so
through these talks I hope we'll get
both a sense of what's possible what are
the range of problems that are
potentially solvable but as well as the
challenges and and this whole question
of how much can we expect from this new
technology